[Music]
in
attention-seekers news submitted by
James from Amsterdam Amsterdam Instagram
models sending their thoughts and
prayers to those affected by Hurricane
Irma so these models
hold on I'm gonna predict that you're
like standing on a [ __ ] boat
like looking at the ocean in a beautiful
place with like a like it's like a yacht
right and then like thoughts and prayers
- right they're like in a bikini like on
the beach or something positive and good
vibes to the islands right now sending
[ __ ] [ __ ] you next one oh my
beautiful st. Maarten today looks like
they got hit pretty bad so keep them in
your pairs just remembering this
peaceful moment the last time I was
there why you gotta make it about you
they only that's all anyone does now
yeah that's what I'm saying sorry I
haven't posted in a while I've been busy
all week preparing for hurricane
Irma to all my Floridians and southern
states Stacy's wait what was she
preparing for Oh Turkey remember the
name of her dildo hurricane Irma will be
the most powerful hurricane Puerto Rico
had in years or ever promised to stay
safe hi this is my I'm really sad
[ __ ] ha ha this is prepare for an
emergency this picture happening right
here and then to the right there's just
dead families no no no I picture
somebody like just got power to their
phone they're huddled up in their
[ __ ] cold you know and they're like
oh hold me they can get help on
Instagram and it's like thoughts and
prayers like guys I'm out a beach
vacation that's the first thing they see
it's unbelievable so now going to David
David you have been posting these
yeah I'm surprised you didn't get flag
amazing the funny thing is it's big
you're welcome I thought those were
orange peels that you cut and if they're
rice crackers know that Asian rice
crackers the hell I thought they were
orange peels so the posts on the first
one if I can read it uh-huh
because I've been noticing that it was
just like because when you go through
your Splore page like two things pop up
for me hot women and like wait for some
reason yeah I know even work out but for
some reason like and this one was very
disturbing McDonald's sponsorship
honestly afraid to check my eldest Wow
Gina not one was [ __ ] hard dude
explain your project so the reason why
I'm doing this on my Instagram well
number one I'm bored of [ __ ] and so I
like to do things that are a little bit
different and weird and pretty hard work
cuz I'm a shot photos in a while so like
lighting was very difficult but this is
like my thing it's like every single
Instagram [ __ ] hole always puts up a
picture it has nothing to do with
[ __ ] anything and they try to act
like they're [ __ ] philanthropist that
they actually care about the [ __ ]
world when they don't and they make it
about themselves so the first thing when
Hurricane Emma started happening or
whatever all these [ __ ] posts just
like that just like that and I was like
well I've been wanting to do this for a
long time and I was like this is the
best time and look at that [ __ ] I can't
believe that [ __ ] brother on the first
picture was I heard a hurricane is
coming to Florida stay safe out there
let's be safe and God bless you all god
is good for that post I know for damn
sure Merrill didn't take those pictures
all Merida was did you not see this
United so you posted it oh no I sent it
to her first
she said gross I think we were at Barton
Gio's place visiting baby Tyga and then
G oh yeah
you were there too and then Gina's like
oh my god David and we're like what
happening we all pull up our phones were
like oh it is so shocking really sad
they review went there yes I did
it's getting only gonna get worse all
right there's more we back following I'm
done with the Instagram whole stuff next
thing I'm doing is to ramble boom you
are singly on Julia Kelly that's kind of
what I've been doing I've been doing
Instagram people in general yeah yeah
the [ __ ] people on Instagram [ __ ] boys
and girls I that's my whole thing on
insta the fact that you over editor yeah
I do a lot of that captions are big very
important part of it but making it all
about you and your stupid [ __ ] life
is the key I think the essence
I wonder what goes on through these
people's minds like when they post this
[ __ ] like do they really think they're
helping and I'm also making fun of the
guys that follow these type of women too
you know because they'll write that and
they'll write stuff like for example
like in the bed like breakfast in bed I
wish has somebody next week and the guy
will drive I could be next to you baby's
gonna [ __ ] read that and be like I've
been looking for you but they think that
though yeah they actually do and they
said the weird dick pic it's like the
guys who like Nikki you be jogging and
some guys like like hey my man all that
[ __ ] and she's like like what am I gonna
[ __ ] go like oh my god the whole
country just whistles as soon as you
land from the plane while you're in the
plane
they're bad over there I was like fully
covered in the wintertime
and I'll still whistle x-ray vision was
like a bunch of nuns that come out of a
bus I know I just saw that yesterday on
Valley Boulevard when I was driving
traffic and I heard some Mexican is honk
lady and it's just this asian mom with
the [ __ ] visor gloves our standards
drive quite a bit do you think she's
like I know you are my wonton and then
they did even more if you like ignore
them or if you talk back to them and
just and it's never helped so you're
saying you don't love it no they've done
that to you when Isaac is walking with
you down the street yeah yeah they don't
care incite the guys next to the girl or
anything they just they just go well you
couldn't be together different races
water homeless guy cuz we were like
holding hands whatever he starts like
yelling [ __ ] and like the homeless man
yeah the homeless man hitting on me and
then talking [ __ ] about me being with
him so what did they do in Mexico like
if if a guy was disrespected because his
woman was catcalled do they all just
like get into fights like what what's
the typical like I really big consensus
because whenever I be walking with my
dad they don't say anything
they're like oh he's the man I I don't
know like they make sense it may be
because you're not Mexican they were
like they're saying you just need a like
give them a nice good roundhouse kick to
the stomach and show them what like
Chinese is all made of yeah you might be
your dad it's like a cartel drug lord
homeless man who wanted to talk [ __ ]
about somebody up I've never seen that
before you know it is pretty good get
your life together he's like
[Laughter]
I think you've got alcohol problem you
should be ashamed of yourself you want
some like financial advice the next
series is going to be Instagram blogger
series so it's like it's not really
making fun of it but it's more like they
kind of like overly dramatize everything
that they do like breakfast and morning
like you don't have breakfast like that
every [ __ ] morning [ __ ] shut the
[ __ ] up we're doing an entire table yeah
and because they always try to fabricate
their lives as if it's the most amazing
thing on earth so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna take what they do but show
like the realism of it so mmm it's fun
like it's kind of one of your butt crack
your nipples it ah we'll see I have one
that's actually pretty [ __ ] bad but I
just didn't like the aesthetic of it's
on impost it but it is I'm basically
butt naked on a pad my ass thinking on
this way but it just it just looks so
bland there wasn't any texture it was
kind of like there was no pastiche yeah
you know I understand it's tough because
the photos have to look good come on now
this is why comedians need to exist in
the world to point out all the [ __ ]
ridiculousness that other people can't
see they used to oh yeah they don't do
it anymore here no more they're all PC
bullshitters now man it drives me
[ __ ] crazy
now somebody wrote on a comment they
were like so you so what do you feel
good about making fun of your Instagram
models and I wrote back and go [ __ ]
die you [ __ ] loser
I make fun to anybody I don't care who
you are I make fun of me too I'm down I
left with the Pope you had a black guy
look come on I love the guy no some
people people get all over my ass
sometimes and I'm like I just made a
joke like the last in the last video
about like why my mom should have died
already I don't care it's like what
what's so wrong about making an
observation it's just like he tie things
together and it works if George cotton
was glad that I did he would be [ __ ]
he wouldn't he wouldn't be able to
believe he'd want to just die ya know
exactly yeah
well cuz he talked about like there are
words you can't say and all that stuff
like here he fought so hard he went to
jail for saying [ __ ] exactly in a public
forum or something and now he would go
to jail for seeing a different f-word
and it's true that's very true it's
unbelievable that's true
[Music]
um I haven't done in a while you know
when you start making money it's tough
to you know get yourself out there no no
I really wanted to get back and do it
honestly do you think the crowd the
climate is different when you when the
last since the last time you did it yeah
cuz every time I do live performances is
to a crowd that already knows who I am
so it's way easier they understand my
humor all that stuff and I don't do
stand-up I just work off improv with
Bart so right because of that they
already know all the inside jokes there
he warmed up to me anything I say is
funny I could just walk up on stage and
say what there's no work behind it yeah
that's the David Spade effect I call
because David Spade who's very funny
comedian yeah but he doesn't have to be
funny no you just keep everyone's like
your dad you're fine so therefore I will
laugh at whatever you say yeah you could
be like hi and so you just do the same
set for 30 years and everything
everyone's happy that's why I like
watching my youtube comedians try to
extend them cuz they think they're so
[ __ ] funny card and they go to these
diner clubs and I just yeah cuz I know
my place I can't do it in a cold crowd I
could only do it to people that already
understand my humor yeah it's just a
different piece like I've seen like a
couple and this makes me feel so good
Bern cuz they talk so much [ __ ] that's
the problem talk a lot of [ __ ] you
shouldn't talk about somebody else's
crap they don't talk about yours just do
your own thing dude but you think the
climate is different now like the crowd
even because I feel like the stand-up
comedy people that go watch that stuff
they're they're older and they're
they're more thick-skinned I thought I
think I don't know well you could say a
lot more in comedy clubs so whatever you
think that is offensive here that means
you haven't been to a comedy club cuz
comedy club is no holds bar and if
you're [ __ ] offended by it through
that [ __ ] comic if they're good they
will roast your [ __ ] ass if they're
good you know sometimes I'm like oh I
hope they pick me you don't want to be
the one that late but thank God you got
lit up you know I'm saying like that's
that's what's so wrong with a lot of
this stuff now I see even people in
YouTube comments and stuff like I can't
believe you talked about this and I'm
like oh is that the sacred cow now cuz
I'm coming
yeah cuz [ __ ] you you know I mean to me
I always have a brick wall behind me I'm
always at a comedy club in my head
because that's the only way that we're
gonna be able to fight all the all the
voices telling you what what's okay to
joke about but the stuff is convenient -
like I always say like there's things
that are off topic because it's
particular to you and that is just your
thing you know you know what I mean so
for example like we I was like in this
writers room and then I did this joke
it was me making fun of somebody who
doesn't understand the concept of what
sexual assault is right
so the comedy isn't the fact that sexual
assault is fun is that this guy's so
[ __ ] stupid
he doesn't understand it right and
they're like no that's off topic so I
brought up another one I was like what
about suicide that's hilarious I was
like what see everybody's moral compass
is so different yeah
so it's only particular to you it's like
violence on TV versus sex on TV yeah he
gives a [ __ ] about violence on TV but
some TVs like that's America nipples are
so [ __ ] scary like I know don't get
it
hey you guys want to stock any of us
we'll go ahead down to the description
box below and you can follow us on
Instagram and all kinds of stuff for
more videos
[Music]
[Music]